[Music]
good morning
i'm shaka king this year's spirit awards
honorary chair welcome to the 2021
spirit awards emerging filmmaker awards
reveal special joining me today
are the very talented former spring
awards grant winners
vel eslin and nan fu wang chosen for
their unique vision
and commitment to the craft we will be
announcing the nominees and winners of
three filmmaker grants today
the someone to watch producers and truer
than fiction awards
these awards are generously supported by
genesis motor north america
and thanks to their commitment each
award winner will receive a 25
000 unrestricted grant our first
emerging filmmaker award
is the summon to watch award which i won
in 2014.
this award honors a talented filmmaker
of singular vision who has not yet
received appropriate recognition
the finalists are david meydell director
of the killing of kenneth chamberlain
ecuamasangi director of farewell amore
and annie silverstein director of bull
all three nominees for the someone to
watch award
brought clear and defective visions to
complex american stories
the winner of this year's award embraced
the richness of human experience to
bring to life three unforgettable
protagonists
this director brilliantly captures the
puzzling act of moving between
cultural and racial contexts through
attention to authentic detail
and persistence of vision the someone to
watch award presented by genesis
goes to equal massage director of
farewell
hi everyone i'm mel eslin the recipient
of the 2016
producers award i am thrilled to be
announcing the 2021 producers award this
award is incredibly meaningful to me in
its uniqueness to honor the often
overlooked creative
and independent producer which honors
emerging producers who
despite highly limited resources
demonstrate the creativity
tenacity and vision required to produce
quality independent films the finalists
this year
are cara duret lucas joaquin jerry kim
the producers award committee had an
overwhelmingly large pool of talented
and hard-working producers to consider
this year
they test themselves with selecting
three producers who are making
high quality work oftentimes with very
limited means
and are creating and providing
opportunities for filmmakers
who are at the start of their career the
committee has chosen to honor a producer
who has consistently pounded the
pavement
irrespective of the setting language or
genre of their films
who is well respected by peers and in
their own words
wants to make films that will help bring
more empathy into a world
that desperately needs it the producers
award
presented by genesis goes to
jerry kim
hello my name is nam fu wong i was the
recipient of the 2017 tour then fiction
award
i'm honored to be here presenting the
2021 truer than fiction award
the truer than fiction award honors an
emerging director of
non-fiction features who has not yet
received
appropriate recognition the finalists
are
cecilia aldorando director of landfall
elegance braden director of peer kids
elizabeth lowe director of stray
the jury was so fortunate to watch a
slate of extraordinary documentaries
that looked at the life's resilient or
wrecked
unsupported yet breathtaking this
director
listens as deeply as they watch holding
space for the characters to share their
stories
the film has a raw vivid intimacy that
goes beyond fly on the wall
to deliver portraits of people living
their dance of authenticity and
performance
boldness and vulnerability the truer
than fiction award
presented by genesis goes to
elegance braden director of peer kids
this whole village is another world
inside the world
if you've come to this area because this
is what we know
as safe zone
congratulations to all the emerging
filmmaker award winners
and nominees of the 2021 film
independence spirit awards
and thanks again to genesis for making
this possible we would also like to
thank all of our sponsors this year
including ifc
bullet frontier whiskey fiji water and
cedar
don't forget to watch the spirit awards
on thursday april 22nd live on ifc at 10
pm eastern
hosted by the extremely talented and
hilarious melissa
senor for more information go to
[Music]
spiritawards.org